you uh it was interesting about your
previous idea pursuit i remember
this time period in the 2011 2010 2011
time period
right when this boom started right you
started that company right after
the financial crisis or there's or
thereabouts yeah i was in business
school actually at the time
um so we kind of had the idea in 2009 10
and 2010 we started building it out and
what we probably should have done
was build out an ats like a greenhouse
or lever but we instead tried to build
out
a recruiting product to help with
referrals at companies and so i
i was that was a great experience for me
i learned a ton um
in kind of launching something for the
very first time but yeah that was an
interesting period of time to start a
company because the
everyone's still recovering from the
financial crisis but there are a lot of
like great companies built out of that
vintage
amazing yeah i mean that's when i
started angel investing was right around
that time so
you know if you if the market crashes in
the next two or three years just so you
know
that is the time i'm going to push all
the chips in which is essentially what i
did during the
this financial crisis that happened in
march and april i just
put my equities in wealthfront on 10 and
poured a bunch of equities and then
started investing in more startups
because i knew there would be a lull
pursuit was a pretty good idea actually
your previous company which was
using social networks and your sort of
um
your network to then win to get bounties
or
you know what do they call them yeah
whatever
a referral bonus right the referral
bonus was a big thing when there was a
talent war
but that business didn't work or it was
just too small of a business
what did you learn she said you learned
a bunch what did you learn about
why it didn't work and then take me
through your process of saying i'm
giving up i'm just going to sell it and
go work it
and lick my wounds and work at facebook
for a couple years
yeah so i had two co-founders who are
also engineers like i'm a software
engineer by background
and we were solving a problem that we
had like scaling engineering teams and
found that most of our
best hires were referrals but there
wasn't a great way to
you know kind of programmatically do
that and
and so you know we actually had a bunch
of ideas on a list and this was just the
first one and we said okay we'll just
try to see how it works so one of my big
lessons is like you do not have that
much time as a company
as soon as you start writing code you're
really entrenching yourself so we
ran it for about a year we launched it i
think we got like
50 60 companies signed up using it and
the real big like oops moment was that
we realized the
people who do that make the most
referrals and are best at making
referrals like i'm sure jason that you
make referrals to your companies all the
time
you're probably a great source of like
you know someone a talented person
looking for like their next thing you're
connecting them to right people
but once you get money involved people
feel weird about it so
yes matter incentives matter so we
actually did
get a lot more sharing of job
opportunities
but people went out of the network in
order to refer those people they didn't
go back through so our kind of thesis
around
money itself could help motivate people
to spread the word about high-value jobs
ended up just not being quite right so
it's interesting everybody's kind of
learned that over time i remember
at my couple startups ago mahalo we had
mahalo answers and quora had done
a q a site and google was actually doing
a question and answer site like quora
and they were paying researchers at
google for this google research project
i forgot the name of it exactly
i might have called it google answers
actually and they had full-time
librarians who you could pay
30 bucks to go research something for
you if you needed it right so if you're
like i need to know more about this and
that was just a particularly hard search
to do they would do it for you
and they and korra added some kind of
gold or some kind of
like way to incent people and you could
earn gold and i could earn gold and
that would help you promote stuff and it
turned out that's not why people
use quora the reason people use quora is
like you did when you started docsen is
like
somebody's like how do i put a password
on a pdf how do i track a pdf and it's
like use doc send
there's like other motivations like
people want to get status and status is
just such a much
bigger motivator for folks
everybody knows that zendesk is the
go-to tool for
customer support it's the gold standard
but what you may not know
is zendesk also offers a suite of sales
tools
designed to remove the difficulties of
sales software so sales teams like yours
can go spend more time on what really
matters to their business
which of course is having better
customer conversations even better
zendesk is offering this suite of sales
tools
plus their industry leading support
software for free
for six months as part of the zendesk
for startups program think about
that along with the free access to all
of zendesk as part of the program you'll
also get access to
zendesk's community of startup founders
and partners who will teach you
all the best practices to better serve
your customers and they'll even offer
dedicated onboarding guidance
and support to get you up and running in
no time steezy one of our great
investments here at launch
they teach people how to dance it's a
subscription service think calm
meditation it's easy for dance they rely
on zendesk and they love it they use the
combination of zendex explorer
and their ticket tagging system so that
they can track
which features their users want and that
they're most excited about
and then they take all of that
information from the customer support
channel
and they give it to the product team
right get six months of zendesk for free
at zendesk.com
twist and to qualify for this program
because they're giving it to you for
free
they just ask that you have under 50
employees and you've raised a series a
or below right so if you're a series b
and you got 100 employees why don't you
go ahead and pay for the product okay
but this is zendesk for startups it's
free
zendesk.com